Je suis vraiment content d'être ici aujourd'hui,
pour vous montrer ce qui va tout juste de sortir de nos laboratoires,
littéralement, et je suis heureux que vous soyez les premiers à pouvoir
le voir en direct, car je pense vraiment que cela va changer
-- vraiment changer -- notre manière d'interagir avec les machines.
Voici une table à dessin rétro-projetée. Elle fait 91 cm de diagonale,
et est équipée d'un capteur multi-points. Les capteurs tactiles ordinaires,
présents dans les bornes ou les tableaux blancs interactifs,
ne peuvent capter qu'un seul point à la fois.
Ceci vous permet de capter plusieurs points à la fois.
Je peux utiliser mes deux mains, je peux faire un accord,
ou encore mieux utiliser mes dix doigts à la fois.
Comme cela.
Les capteurs multi-points ne sont pas complètement nouveaux.
Des personnes comme Bill Buxton s'en sont servi dans les années 80.
Cependant, mon approche se sert de la haute résolution,
est peu chère, et sûrement le plus important, très évolutive.
La chose la plus excitante ici n'est donc pas la technologie,
mais surtout les nouvelles possibilités d'accès.
Ce qui est vraiment intéressant est ce que l'on peut en faire,
et le type d'interfaces que l'on peut construire. Voyons ça.
Par exemple, voici une application de lampe à lave. Vous voyez,
j'utilise mes deux mains pour presser les bulles de lave les unes contre les autres.
Je peux injecter de la chaleur dans le système,
ou le diviser avec deux doigts.
C'est complètement intuitif, il n'y a pas de mode d'emploi.
L'interface devient transparente.
Ceci a débuté sous la forme d'un économiseur d'écran fait par un des étudiants
de notre laboratoire, Ilya Rosenberg. Mais sa véritable identité émerge ici.
Ce qui est génial dans un capteur multi-point, c'est
que je peux faire cela avec autant de doigts que je veux,
mais aussi, sous-entendu, avec plusieurs utilisateurs.
Chris peut donc interagir avec une autre partie de la lave,
pendant que je joue ici. On peut imaginer un nouvel outil de sculpture,
en chauffant la matière, la rendant malléable,
puis en la laissant refroidir et se solidifier dans un certain état.
Google devrait avoir quelque chose comme ça dans leur hall. (Rires)
Je vais vous montrer -- un exemple un peu plus concret, pendant que cela charge.
Voici une application de table lumineuse pour photographe.
Ici encore, je peux utiliser mes deux mains pour interagir et bouger les photos.
Encore mieux: avec deux doigts,
je peux prendre une photo et l'étirer comme cela très facilement.
Je peux faire un panoramique, zoomer ou la tourner sans effort.
Je peux faire cela grossièrement avec mes deux mains,
ou juste avec deux doigts de chacune de mes mains en même temps.
Si je prends l'ensemble, je peux faire la même chose -- l'étirer.
Je peux le faire en même temps, où je tiens ceci en bas,
et je saisis l'autre côté, en l'étirant ainsi.
A nouveau, l'interface devient transparente.
Pas de mode d'emploi. C'est exactement que l'on attend,
surtout si vous ne vous êtes jamais servi d'un ordinateur auparavant.
Avec des initiatives comme l'ordinateur à 100 dollars,
l'idée me hérisse que nous créions une nouvelle génération
d'utilisateurs se servant de l'interface standard que sont la souris et les fenêtres.
Je pense que ceci est vraiment la manière dont nous devrions interagir avec les
machines désormais. (Applaudissements)
Bien sûr, je peux ajouter un clavier.
Et cela aussi, placer cela ici, et ça là.
Évidemment, c'est un clavier standard,
mais je peux le redimensionner pour qu'il soit adapté à mes mains.
C'est vraiment important, il n'y a plus de raison de nos jours pour
que nous soyons obligés de notre adapter à un équipement.
Cela peut générer des troubles musculosquelettiques.
La technologie étant si présente de nos jours,
les interfaces devraient commencer à s'adapter à nous.
Très peu a été fait pour améliorer
la manière d'interagir avec les interfaces de travail.
Ce clavier ne va très certainement pas dans la bonne direction.
Vous pouvez imaginer, plus tard, quand cette technologie sera mature,
un clavier qui dérive en même temps que vos mains se déplacent,
qui anticipe intelligemment sur quelle touche vous essayez de taper.
N'est-ce pas génial?
Public : Où est votre laboratoire?
Jeff Han : Je suis un chercheur de l'Université de New York.
Voici un autre exemple d'application. Prenez ces petites boules.
Elles retiendront mes mouvements. Bien sûr, je peux le faire avec mes deux mains.
Elles sont sensibles à la pression, comme vous le voyez.
Mais ce qui super, à nouveau, c'est ce geste avec deux doigts pour
zoomer très rapidement. Puisque vous n'avez pas à passer sur un outil manuel
ou la loupe,
vous pouvez faire des choses sans vous arrêter, à plusieurs échelles, en même temps.
Je peux créer de grands objets ici, mais je peux retourner très vite
au début, et créer des objets encore plus petits ici.
Ceci va devenir très important avec le développement de la
visualisation des données. Par exemple, rappelez-vous la présentation de Hans Rosling
où il a vraiment mis l'accent sur ce que je pense depuis longtemps :
nous avons des données nombreuses, mais, pour diverses raisons, inexploitées.
Nous n'y accédons pas vraiment. C'est pourquoi, à mon avis,
nous serons aidés par des graphiques et des outils de visualisation et d'inférence.
Je pense donc que tout ça commencera grâce à de meilleures interfaces
capables d'aller dans le détail des données, tout en pensant à la vue globale, ici.
Voici une autre application. Elle s'appelle WorldWind.
C'est fait par la NASA. C'est -- nous avons tous vu Google Earth,
c'est une version en logiciel libre. Il y a des connecteurs capables
de charger différents ensembles de données que la NASA a amassés au fil des ans.
Mais comme vous le voyez, je peux utiliser les mêmes gestes des doigts
pour zoomer en profondeur sans rupture. Pas d'interface, à nouveau.
Cela permet à n'importe qui de zoomer -- cela fait ce à quoi vous vous attendez,
vous voyez? Encore, pas d'interface. Elle disparaît tout simplement.
Je peux passer d'une vue à l'autre. C'est ce qui super avec cette application.
Voilà. La NASA est vraiment sympa. Ils ont ces images hyper-spectrales
qui sont colorisées pour -- c'est vraiment pratique pour déterminer l'usage végétal. Bref, revenons à notre sujet.
Le grand intérêt des applications de cartographies --
ce n'est pas en 2D, plutôt en 3D. A nouveau, avec une interface multi-points,
vous pouvez faire un geste ainsi -- et être capable d'incliner comme ça,
Ce n'est vraiment pas qu'un simple mouvement de déplacement en 2D.
Ce geste que nous avons développé, à nouveau, juste avec deux doigts,
définit un axe d'inclinaison et vous pouvez incliner vers le haut ou le bas ainsi.
C'est venu naturellement sur le moment,
ce n'est probablement pas la bonne chose à faire,
mais vous pouvez faire tellement de choses intéressantes avec ces interfaces.
C'est aussi très amusant de jouer avec. (Rires)
La dernière chose que je veux vous montrer est --
je suis sûr que nous pouvons tous imaginer des applications de
divertissement avec ceci.
Je suis un peu plus intéressé par les applications créatives.
Enfin, voici une application toute simple -- Je dessine une courbe.
Quand je la ferme, cela devient un personnage.
Le truc sympa, c'est que je peux ajouter des points de contrôle.
Ensuite, je peux les manipuler avec mes deux doigts en même temps.
Regardez ce qui se passe.
C'est comme une marionnette, où j'utilise
tous les doigts possibles pour dessiner et créer --
Il y a beaucoup de calculs derrière
pour arriver à contrôler cet engrenage et obtenir le résultat voulu.
En clair, cette technique pour manipuler ici un engrenage,
avec plusieurs points de contrôle, est en fait l'état de l'art.
Cela vient juste de sortir à Siggraph l'an dernier,
mais c'est un super exemple du type de recherche que j'aime.
Toute cette puissance de calcul pour faire des choses utiles.
Intuitivement. Exactement ce que vous attendez.
La recherche sur l'interaction multi-point est très active en ce moment dans le domaine des interfaces homme-machine
Je ne suis pas tout seul, beaucoup de gens s'y mettent.
Cette technologie permettra à plus de gens de s'y mettre,
je suis très impatient d'interagir avec vous tous
dans les jours à venir et de voir comme cela pourra s'appliquer dans vos domaines respectifs.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)